madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la séance est reprise et nous en
arrivons la question 153 de monsieur
rémy pointereau à madame le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur vincent peillon et concerne la
réforme des rythmes scolaires qui porte
notamment sur le retour d'une semaine à
quatre jours et demi et qui pose
quelques difficultés comme vous le savez
non pas sur le fond mais surtout sur la
forme et je remercie madame pau-langevin
ministre chargé de la réussite éducative
de bien vouloir me répondre
tout d'abord en termes de concertation
dont on nous disait qu'un consensus
existe et je n'en suis pas tout à fait
sûr ainsi en octobre dans mon
département du cher une consultation
dans les 300 écoles du cher représentant
1200 personnes au total dont 800
professeurs des écoles et 400 parents
d'élèves laisser apparaître au contraire
un rejet du retour à la demi journée
supplémentaire de cours d'autre part une
réunion a été organisée à l'attention
des élus du cher le 18 février dernier à
la demande du directeur académique et
sous la présidence du préfet du cher
réunion à laquelle l'association des
maires du cher que je préside a bien
voulu s'associer
lors de cette réunion plus de 200 élus
étaient présents et je peux vous dire
qu'ils étaient tous inquiets j'ai
rappelé qu'une motion avait été adoptée
lors de notre dernière assemblée
générale extraordinaire réunie sur ce
sujet et compte tenu des délais
extrêmement contraint l'unanimité des
élus présents ont demandé le report de
la réforme à la rentrée 2014
les élus sont conscients qu'il faut
mettre en avant bien sûr l'intérêt de
l'enfant et qu'il ne s'agit en aucun cas
d'une position politique puisque même de
nombreux élus de toutes sensibilités
confondues droite et gauche partagent le
même avis toutefois il faut permettre
aux communes de s'organiser dans les
meilleures conditions
s'agissant notamment du temps
périscolaire avec l'obligation de
recruter du personnel adapté
générant ainsi un coût financier
important pour les communes estimée
environ 150 euros par élève
d'autre part s'agissant des transports
scolaires dont les conseils généraux ont
la charge le coût supplémentaire pour
les conseils généraux est estimée pour
le cher entre 500 mille et un million
deux cent mille euros pour notre
département enfin cela risque de créer
des inégalités territoriales
compte tenu qu'il faudra mettre à
disposition des locaux supplémentaires
afin de mettre en place des activités
culturelles sportives et autres et en
milieu rural cela sera beaucoup plus
difficile
enfin pour inciter les communes de le
gouvernement a décidé en décembre
d'accorder une aide de 50 euros par
élève avec une majoration pouvant aller
jusqu'à 40 euros dans les communes
urbaines ou rurales les plus en
difficulté afin d'inciter les communes
appliquer la réforme dans le primaire
dès 2013 madame la ministre commencera
financer ce fonds de 250 millions pour
les d'euros pour les rentrée 2013 et
et que va-t-il se passer ensuite pour
les anglais rentrée suivante comment
allez vous identifier les communes
rurales et urbaines les plus en
difficulté et d'autre part allez-vous
compenser à l'euro près
cette dépense nouvelles imposées aux
conseils généraux depuis lors
l'association des maires de france a
fait savoir qu'un nombre important de
communes ne pourraient en me serais en
mesure d'appliquer la réforme des
rythmes scolaires avant 2014
malgré ce malgré sa volonté je cite de
sauver la réforme elle a estimé comme je
le dis tout à l'heure à 150 euros par
enfant le coût réel de la réforme alors
même que des annonces viennent d'être
faites il y à quelques jours d'une
réduction des dotations aux
collectivités de 4,5 milliards d'euros
sur 2014 et 2015
comment comptez vous faire pour rassurer
les maires sur le soutien pérenne de
l'état
écoutez les élus locaux ils sont
suffisamment sollicités et ne le
remettons pas la pression pour une
application anticipée qui ne peuvent
assumer
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame george pau-langevin mini chargé
de la réussite éducative
merci monsieur le président
mais les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
point trop je crois que nous devons
d'abord nous rappeler pourquoi nous
faisons cette réforme
vous savez que notre pays est
actuellement en difficulté dans les
évaluations internationales que notre
système éducatif n'est plus performant
comme nous le souhaiterions
et comme il serait nécessaire pour que
notre pays garde la compétitivité
indispensables notamment au maintien des
emplois
par conséquent il est urgent de redonner
à nos enfants de bonnes conditions pour
qu'ils puissent étudier
c'est le constat auquel étaient parvenus
la concertation qui avaient été menées
notamment sous l'égide de luc chatel
entre 2010 et 2012 qui avait abouti à la
nécessité de revoir l'organisation de
notre système éducatif et notamment de
revoir les rythmes scolaires
ensuite il ya eu un appel de bobigny en
fait je ne connais pas de personnes
compétentes le sujet ayant étudié le
sujet qui ne disent pas que nous devons
rapidement revoir l'organisation de
notre semaine scolaire parce que nous
donnons plus aux enfants de ce pays
des bonnes conditions pour étudier et
surtout le temps nécessaire pour étudier
donc les remettre en classe une matinée
supplémentaire est une chose
indispensable pour qu'ils puissent
travailler correctement
à partir de là effectivement il y aura
un certain nombre de difficultés à
affronter comme à chaque fois qu'on fait
un changement donc nous savons que les
élus ont des préoccupations et
évidemment nous sommes convenons qu'il
est légitime de leur part de se demander
comment ils vont faire pour mettre en
oeuvre la réforme mais il me semble que
si on est conscient de ce que cette
réforme est utile et indispensable
alors là on peut parler sur les
modalités de mise en application
mais sur le principe déjà si nous sommes
convaincus qu on doit le faire
ceux ci changent déjà les choses et si
on est conscient de ce que c'est bien
pour les enfants et que c'est une
manière de les aider à étudier
je crois que retarder d'année en année
n'est pas une chose tout à fait
souhaitable
alors vous savez que justement le
calendrier a été assouplie
vous avez la possibilité de passer en
2013 ou en 2014
vous savez aussi que nous avons proposé
la possibilité d'assouplir on peut
passer le choisir de revenir à l'école
mercredi matin au lieu du samedi matin
si c'est plus facile pour certains élus
par ailleurs vous avez parlé justement
des inquiétudes des élus quant au
financement de cet orgue réorganisation
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
fonds d'amorçage a été créé qui donne
aux communes une dotation de 50 euros
par élève et 40 euros pour les communes
qui sont les plus en difficulté comment
on va choisir les plus en difficulté
c'est un truc objectif c'est à dire
qu'il ya celles qui bénéficient de la
dsu cible et celles qui bénéficient de
la dsr cible donc là encore ce ne sera
pas un tri que nous aurons à faire donc
ce qui sera important aussi c'est qu'on
va s'organiser vous allez devoir
organiser entre les services de
l'éducation nationale les élus les les
associations qui aident aussi vont jouer
un rôle et par conséquent nous sommes
intimement persuadés que ce faisant on
va pouvoir améliorer la démocratie
locale et que tous les acteurs qui
interviennent dans l'éducation de nos
enfants seront amenés à s'organiser
donc c'est vrai c'est un petit peu une
manière nouvelle de travail et c'est
sans doute un effort pour lisier les
autres mais je crois que le bien-être de
nos enfants vont bien que nous fassions
cet effort merci madame la ministre
monsieur point trop oui j'ai merci de
tout d'abord madame lise de votre de
votre réponse
même si elle ne me satisfait pas bien
sûr tout à fait puisque c'est vrai que
nous étions autrefois à la semaine de
quatre jours et demi et si cela avait
procuré du bien-être à nos enfants
peut-être qu'on le saurait et on aurait
déjà des résultats
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure les élus
sont conscients bien sûr que c'est
l'intérêt de l'enfant qui prime dans
cette dans cette réforme mais toutefois
il faut mettre les meilleures conditions
pour la mise en oeuvre de cette de cette
réforme
et c'est un peu précipité 2013 est trop
précipité par rapport aux aux moyens à
mettre en oeuvre des locaux
supplémentaires qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre et surtout les moyens financiers
vous me parlez de 2 mètres 50 euros à
disposition des communes qui pourront le
faire dès 2013 qu'en sera-t-il à 2014
et qu'en sera-t-il pour les années à
venir avec des budgets qui sont
contraints et comme je le dis tout à
l'heure avec des dotations qui vont
baisser de 4,5 milliards d'euros dans
les prochaines années 2014 et 2015
c'est presque 5% de dgf pour les
communes qui vont être impactés
alors je veux pause je vous pose la
question comment tout cela sera financé
y compris pour les conseils généraux qui
sont déjà bien impactées dans leur
budget et qu'ils vont être bien sûr
imposées par cette réforme de leurs deux
pour notre département cinq cent mille à
un million deux cent mille euros
je vous ai pas répondu sur cette
question est ce que vous allez compenser
les conseils généraux à l'euro près
comme ç'avait été la demande pendant des
années on a entendu ça en boucle dans
nos hémicycle respectif
je vois savoir qui va financer qui va
payer tout cela
merci mon show connaît madame réunissent
je vous en prie nous avons le temps je
voudrais simplement monsieur le sénateur
rappeler une chose c'est que le nombre
d'heures durant lesquelles l'enfant sera
à l'école sera strictement le même
par conséquent il n'y a pas si vous
voulez de la part de l'état une espèce
de diminution de ses obligations il y à
une réorganisation est ce que cette
réforme fait apparaître
c'est surtout elle ne crée pas des
inégalités elle fait apparaître que dans
notre pays il y a aujourd'hui des
inégalités significative selon les
communes où on arrive où elle habite
parce que le périscolaire est plus ou
moins bien organisée au fond ce que ça
vous donne à réfléchir
c'est à dire mais oui c'est vrai
actuellement actuellement l'état prendra
exactement la même chose
effectivement vous dites il y aura des
efforts financiers mais il faut bien
voir que de la part de
du budget de l'état il y a aussi un
effort financier considérable qui est
fait pour pouvoir répondre à cet
objectif qui avait été signalé comme
prioritaires qui est de dire que
l'éducation est une priorité à un moment
où on fait des économies partout et dans
beaucoup de ministères
il est clair que lorsque mon métier est
la priorité qui a été annoncé à
l'éducation c'est en faisant des
économies
par ailleurs par conséquent
effectivement si nous sommes d'accord
sur l'idée que l'avenir de nos enfants
est quelque chose d'essentiel
je pense que l'état fait largement sa
part or en respectant sa parole et en
respectant cette priorité il est évident
que aujourd'hui il y a un effort a
demandé aux collectivités locales
mais je suis persuadé que la plupart
d'entre elles sont prêtes à faire cet
effort parce qu'elles sont convaincus
que c'est l'avenir de notre pays
merci madame la ministre nous allons
attendre quelques instants l'arrivée du
ministre de l'intérieur